Speaker 1: Let's continue our coverage of
this absolutely incredible situation in
which we find ourselves here, where a former
president is under criminal investigation
for a whole bunch of different potential
crimes. One of the latest very bizarre.
It's not even really a side story, but details
and what's going on is that Donald Trump bizarrely
sent a message to Attorney General Merrick Garland
through intermediaries over the last few days. And
it's genuinely unclear at this point in time
whether Donald Trump is in some way trying to
tamper with or obstruct the investigation, or
whether Trump is alluding to the possibility
of taking some kind of a plea deal. It's at this
point, I am not sure what the point of this is,
but I will tell you what is known and we can sort
of go from there. This was a paragraph almost at
the bottom of a New York Times article. The New
York Times article is called Trump lawyer told
Justice Department that classified material
had been returned. Now, the top line of this
about the returned material. Is important
and it is relevant and it also appears to be
untrue and raises one set of questions. And that
set of questions is, it seems as though Trump's
lawyers really did say early in June that all
of the materials in question had been returned.
Obviously the FBI didn't believe that because
ultimately they executed a search warrant. And it
does appear as though the FBI was correct in their
suspicions that not everything had been returned.
There a question as to whether did Trump's
lawyers knowingly lie at that point?
Were Trump's lawyers lied to about the documents?
We don't know. But that's not what I want to focus
in on today. If you look at this article and
you start scrolling, scrolling, scrolling all
the way down to almost the very bottom, there is
a very interesting there's two paragraphs that
are very interesting, and they read as follows.
Shortly before Mr. Garland made the announcement
recently about that, Merrick Garland made a
small statement about this search warrant.
Speaker 2: A person close.
Speaker 1: To Mr. Trump reached out to a Justice
Department official to pass along a message from
the former president to the attorney general.
Mr. Trump wanted Mr. Garland to know that he had
been checking in with people around the country
and found them to be enraged by the search.
The message Trump wanted conveyed, according
to a person familiar with the exchange, was The
country is on fire. What can I do to reduce the
heat? What can I do to reduce the heat? Now, this
could be interpreted a couple of different ways.
There is more than a couple. In fact, there is,
of course, the kind of mob boss interpretation.
This would not be new for Trump. Nice, nice
business you got here. Would really be a shame
if something happened to it, right? The idea that
a lot of people are angry here. Merrick Garland. A
lot of people are angry. What can we do together
so that those people will be less angry? And so
one interpretation is these angry people. Unless
you do something to help me, might go after you.
They might go after your family, they might go
after FBI agents. And all of those individuals are
receiving death threats, all sorts of security
threats. We're going to talk about that in a
moment, because this is a this is a group Trump
is a guy with a constituency. A constituency
sounds almost more than it is, which is
like a depraved cult following with a
constituency that is willing to do violence.
We know that from January 6th. So that could
be one interpretation. This is like a mob boss
message to Merrick Garland. The second one is.
Would I be? Is it possible I could get some kind
of a plea deal? Could we do something to make this
go away now again? It's sort of more subtle and
nuanced than I think Trump is known for. But it
was through someone close to Trump, maybe someone
with slightly better, you know, capable of more
nuance than Donald Trump. And so that would
be what can we do to calm everything down?
Maybe you charged me with something minor
and symbolic, and I plead guilty and we go
from there. It's not very much like Trump because
Trump Trump doesn't apologize and pleading guilty
is sort of like the legal version of an apology.
It doesn't mean you actually are remorseful,
but in a sense you're admitting you did something
wrong, at least to some degree. But of course,
Trump would never actually do that. He
would say, I agreed to do it, to do this.
I agreed to plead guilty to this because otherwise
the witch hunt would go on forever. It wouldn't
allow me to run all these different things. So
that's another possibility. The third possibility
is this is like a general tampering message of
some kind that Donald Trump is just trying to.
Interfere with in some way contact the individual
at the top of the organization that is that is
involved in the investigation. It's not really
clear. Now, of course, Trump could just take
responsibility for what he did and say, I did the
wrong thing here. It was unknowing unknowingly. I
did the wrong thing. And that's it. But that
is not what Trump does. Trump doesn't really
take please, Trump doesn't apologize. Trump
doesn't admit wrongdoing. So that's what we
have as of right now. And it will be a matter
of seeing where these attempted contacts to
Merrick Garland go now. Next, let's talk about the
actual threats to individuals and law enforcement.